Speaker 1: You all know my feelings about
Donald Trump.
I think he's a complete and total doofus,
dangerous, wannabe authoritarian dictator,
liar, con man, grifter.
You all know that.
The DeSantis campaign launch was so bad that
it made Donald Trump's memes and posts to
truth.
Social censure actually make Trump seem like
a funny and clever guy.
And a couple of people wrote to me and said,
Wow, your brain is so broken, David, that
now you think Trump looks good.
You know, the same people who are saying you're
too critical of Trump, you have Trump Derangement
syndrome are now telling me I'm deranged because
I think that the DeSantis event made Trump
look better.
Trump's campaign now looks like it is functioning
properly.
That's how bad the DeSantis launch was.
Trump posted this video to Troth Central,
and it's a contrasting video of Trump's launch
and the DeSantis launch.
It's genuinely funny.
Take a look at this.
Take a listen to this and you'll see when
you hear the country song, it's Trump's campaign
launch.
And then when you hear audio feedback loops,
it's the DeSantis Twitter Spaces launch.
This is genuinely funny.
Here we go.
To be an American.
Speaker 2: We are kind of melting the surface.
Unidentified: The DNA American where it is.
I.
Speaker 2: Time to freedom and put his money
where his mouth is.
Something here obsession by our government
who.
Unidentified: Came back to make America.
Speaker 2: Have coverage sent us because.
Speaker 1: Okay.
So what is amazing about this is there are
levels of things.
There are levels of disasters when we many
of us cop a few, 20,000 of us or so watched
the Trump campaign announcement together.
We did a livestream, beautiful livestream,
some say the best.
And when Trump comes out and he's all Stefani
standing there, hinging back and forth and
leaning forward and God Bless the USA is playing
and a crowd of Mar a Lago sycophants is almost,
you know, peeing their pants in titillated
pleasure over the presence of Donald Trump.
We look at it and we say, this is a humiliation.
How we after all these years dating back to
2015, this disastrous Trump campaign, blah,
blah, all this stuff, how are these people?
This is this is humiliating.
And Trump looks like what could possibly be
worse than this.
And then what's worse is DeSantis tries to
announce his candidacy on Twitter spaces,
and it goes horribly wrong.
By the time it starts 25 minutes late due
to a technical disaster, DeSantis just talks
about woke, woke, woke, reading a prepared
speech on Twitter.
And you realize, well, the Trump event was
the previous bottom of the barrel.
But DeSantis is far, far, far worse.
And now we go, Well, the Trump event, I guess,
wasn't that bad.
Now, meanwhile, over on Truth, Social Trump
really getting a lot of mileage out of this.
And it'll be interesting to see where the
polling goes as a result of this fiasco.
Trump posting to troth, quote, Rob my red
button so he calls Ron DeSantis.
Rob Now, I don't even know where that comes
from.
Rob My red button is bigger, better, stronger,
and is working.
Truth Yours does not.
Per my conversation with Kim Jong un of North
Korea, soon to become my friend, then continuing.
Wow, the Desanctis Twitter launch is a disaster.
His whole campaign will be a disaster.
Watch Trump continuing at this genuinely is
funny.
Tim Scott's presidential launch even with
the broken microphone, don't pay the contractor.
Tim was by far the best presidential lot launch
of the week.
Rob's was a catastrophe.
And then lastly, Trump Atrophying.
Is the DeSantis launch fatal?
Yes.
So a self-inflicted error for sure.
Later on in the evening, DeSantis appeared
on Fox News to talk policy, and that was a
disaster.
We'll talk later.
But but, but but before we assume too much
dissent is continues to gain in the polls
against Trump, since news of the announcement
broke, what you see on the screen, the Purple
line is Trump and the Green line is the Santos.
As you can see, starting in late March, when
news of Trump's arrest went public, it was
just up, up, up for Trump going from 44 to
56 in the Republican primary and DeSantis
falling from a high of 30 all the way down
to 19.
But.
But since news broke that DeSantis would be
announcing DeSantis climbing from 19 to 21
and Trump dropping from 56 to 54, is it a
big change?
No.
But is it an inflection point?
Is MAGA going to abandon Trump?
Are we going to see this as the inevitable
rise of Ron DeSantis?
We have to wait and see.
After the break, we will look at Desantis's
first major interview as a 2024 presidential
candidate.
And I will warn you, it is tough to watch.
Remember that Monday, Memorial Day now just
a few days away, we will be offering a one
day membership special.
This is our end of May launch 2024 Discounted
membership special one day only.
If you'd like to be notified of how to sign
up for a criminally inexpensive membership
on Monday, simply get on my newsletter at
David Packman dot com.
We'll take a quick break.
It is a hell of a program today.